Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conner, so I'm going to do a little exposé on royal
rife and his work.
For those who don't know anything about the rife machine, I'm certainly not an expert
in the clinician and we use it with unbelievable success at our office, but I'm not a quantum
physicist, and that's really how frequency medicine works.
So this is going to be a brief overview, so don't critique it through the eyes of a quantum
physicist because you may be disappointed.
Royal rife is where we get the name rife from, royal rife is a man, royal raman rife.
He lived from 1888 to 1971, studied at John Hopkins and he was really a microbiologist
in a microscope manufacturer.
He has numerous credits to his name, many people in his day and since then have considered
him a genius, and just what he studied and what he discovered was amazing, he really discovered
the first live cell, microscope, he actually built it, and could see living, moving bacteria
as they moved through the blood of a patient, and it was quite interesting what he discovered.
He credited many times with dinners and his otter, he was very accredited in his day where
he got trouble is what we're going to see.
From a quantum physics perspective, understand that the smallest particles that we know are
simply energy that is vibrating at a specific frequency.
So from a Newtonian physics perspective, things are broken down to an atom structure which
is surrounded electrons, surrounded proton and a neutron, and from a quantum physics perspective
it's the smallest particle is simply energy, and what makes it different is its vibrational
field.
So it vibrates at a specific frequency, that's what makes it what it is.
So all matter is everything that you can see and its smallest particle is energy that
vibrates at a specific frequency.
You can measure those frequencies, the average body, organ frequencies are listed here, all
your cells vibrated at a specific frequency, the conglomeration of cells that is an organ,
a tissue will vibrate at a specific frequency, cancer will vibrate at a specific frequency,
the virus is bacteria, vibrate at a specific frequency, and if you hit those tissues, those
organs with their own frequency, good things can happen.
So that's what his work really surrounded around in the latter part of his life, and that's
what got him in trouble.
So this picture here shows him with one of his microscopes, at that time it was the world's
most powerful microscope, he lived in San Diego, he called it the Rife Universal Microscope,
which had nearly 6,000 different parts to it, and he could magnify up to 60,000 times its
normal size.
It was an amazing piece of equipment at the time, which is now completely lost, which you'll
find out in just a little bit here.
He also then studied frequency medicine, and how he could create an instrument that when
he could view that virus or that bacteria, he could destroy it with using the frequencies
that would affect that virus or bacteria.
He called that frequency the mortal oscillatory rate, he believed that when he hit that
microbe with its own frequency, he caused it to vibrate.
Well, in his belief at the time that the vibration of that paramecium would then cause it to
be unstable and the cell wall to break down in the organism would lice or die, and he called
that the mortal oscillatory rate.
No, with further studies at this date, they found that in single cell organisms that can
be true, but more so than just that, when you hit anything with its own frequency, you do
cause it to vibrate, and that vibration, because you're matching frequencies with that substance,
whether it be better or a living, a living organism can be very good for the organism or
can be very bad for the organism.
If it's a pathogenic organism in the person's body, your immune system is not unable to find
it if you cause it to vibrate, let's say it's Lyme disease, and you cause it to vibrate,
you attract the attention of lymphocytes and macrophages that could then kill it.
So there's huge benefit of using a rife to kill bacteria that are maybe have the ability
to hide from antibiotics or from a normal elicited immune response by your body.
So something like chronic Lyme disease or a bacteria that is resistant to antibiotics,
you see the rife machine can be very beneficial.
The other benefit of a rife machine using it to kill microbes is simply that there's no
side effects of antibiotics.
It kills them directly or by eliciting a direct immune response on that system.
It doesn't kill it to stimulate the immune response, it kills it by having the immune system
be able to recognize where it is.
And cancer cells, just the simple act of vibrating a growing cancer mass is hugely beneficial
because when a cancer is growing as you learn some of my other lectures, that growing cancer
mass is highly metabolic and that highly metabolic activity that cancer mass is giving a lot
of waste and because of the adhesion molecule, molecules allow you those cancer cells to
could collaborate and basically stick together that excess waste of that metabolic cycle because
of the rapid replication is basically forming a acidic slime layer around the cancer which
it is since is protecting the cancer from an immune response.
So simply vibrating that cancer mass from a cellular point of view is causing a breakup
of that acidic slime layer.
It's allowing your lymphatic system to help carry that away and allowing your immune system
to be able to penetrate that layer to help kill the cancer.
Now there's many other things that the rife does because it's a light generating tool.
It is giving a photon which is basically an electron donation which increases the alkalinity
of whatever you're hitting too.
If you are using it for treating a cancer, you are vibrating the tissue, you are alkalizing
the cancer site directly similar to what Dr. Sima Cheedy's work is which is injecting
sodium bicarb while you are doing it without injecting anything and you are alkalizing the
tissue site and it's just can be very beneficial for the patient and you are also because it's
a less stable structure, you are causing cell lysis which is cell death as well.
So there's many benefits and there's probably two dozen other theories on why frequency
medicine works that is beyond my understanding, I just care that it works.
But this is how rife really started and when he got attention for using his, what he called
his b-brae at the time which is a rife machine which is simply a light frequency generator.
When he used that light frequency generator and he saw changes in microbes, he started to
get attention from the world, newspaper articles like these were written and at that time there
was a kind of a dichotomy in medicine, there are a lot of practicing medical physicians
that want to grab on to what he was doing because their soul desire was to help patients
get better.
But there was a slowly growing medical, pharmaceutical conglomeration that was soon to squish out anything
that was not using a pharmacological approach to treating any disease and that was royal
rife's soon undoing.
So benefacted in 1934, the University of Southern California, the medical school took on rife's
work, said to him a number of terminal cancer patients that all of their medical doctors
believed had weeks to live and the results were phenomenal.
He had just phenomenal results with those cancer patients, benefact every one of those cancer
patients got better.
Now I don't know what kind of studies could be done today, this obviously this would never
be performed today, those doctors who referred people to rife for his work would all be fired
or thrown into jail in today's world because it's not so much, you know, an individual, even
if they're your oncologists want to do natural approaches with you, they are bound by the
organization that they work for, which is the hospital to follow what is called the standard
protocol of medical care, which ironically is written by the pharmaceutical industry.
So the chance of your doctor even recommended vitamin C to you is pretty slim and even clinics
large clinics like Mayo and John Hopkins and Sloan Ketterie who profess to have an alternative
cancer approach in their protocol really basically give lip service to it, they make their
buddy selling drugs.
So that's where they're going to make their money.
There's nobody in selling rife machines, there's nobody in selling vitamins and doing what
I do, there's just nobody in it, when a cancer patient walks into Sloan Ketterie and that
cancer patient's worth anywhere from $100,000 to over a billion dollars and you could buy
a rife machine and do a natural approach for less than $20,000, you are not going to get any
recommendations in this matter, a matter of fact you're going to get slashed and that's exactly
what happened to rife, he went the same route as Gerson and Hoxie and a number of other clinicians
who are seeing unbelievable results with cancer patients using nutraceutical approaches, no
rife uses solely a frequency approach, there's nothing in the literature that I have seen
that he used any nutraceuticals, any nutritional or diet or anything like that, he solely used
his frequency generator, his light frequency generator and he had great results, well Gerson
used basically a diet to juice seed and coffee animals, had great results, Hoxie used his herbal
formula, had a little results but that was right in the early 1950s where the pharmaceutical
industry really took over the AMA and just shut down all these clinics and it's shunny
down these clinics, it basically drove most of these clinics to Mexico and that's the
Mexico Cancer Clinic that we have today, so rife did it go that route when he was shut down
and his place was destroyed, his laboratory was vandalized, his microscope was stolen, his frequency
generator was destroyed, he was up there in years and even though he lived closer to the
Mexico border than any of the other clinicians he basically just gave up, he was done, he was
finished, he was crushed, all his work was destroyed, he was discredited and his work was basically
lost for decades, that's very unfortunate because a lot of people suffered because of that, so
this unfortunately is what happens to anybody who's going to go against a medical pharmaceutical
establishment including us, so this presentation being out there and our name on it is enough
to create a target on our back and that's we've had a target on our back for many, many years
and I've been drug in front of this board and I've been said letters by medical boards, et
cetera and I just ask that you pray for us, we practice solely under our pastoral medical
license, solely under biblical principles and that has been given us, you know, given the
protection, we just believe that the Holy Spirit has his hand on us in order for us to help people
get better, but there's a lot of current information that's written about rice use today, you know,
was picked up again in the early 60s and 70s, actually the US government picked it up in the
cold war and they were trying to create a germ warfare if they thought well if this guy could
actually help people help kill germs with frequencies, couldn't we, by hitting somebody with the
with the frequency of anthrax, couldn't we create anthrax in a person? Well, the positive and
negative of the US defense department picking up rife's work and trying to create, you know,
trying to kill people with it was that they spent millions of dollars mapping out the quantum
physics frequency of every disease known to man at that time and most human body organs in general,
they gave us that all those frequencies and with the Freedom of Information Act, you could Google it
and see those frequencies that they came up with, which really helped the alternative cancer rife
industry is we started building rife machines again from what we do, which are the frequency generators
that rife used, we were able to use those frequencies to be able to help people. The defense department
eventually dropped everything because if you hit somebody with the anthrax frequency, you don't create
anthrax, you will just kill anthrax in that person's body. So, well it didn't work as a germ warfare, but it
does work as medicine and it's erotic, that medicine just ignores it and it gets down to, I hate to say it,
the negative side of capitalism is that if you can't make money at it, well then we just will pretend
it doesn't exist and we'll bash anybody that uses it. That's kind of where we're at. So, there's many,
many cancer books that are out on the market that talk about natural cures if any of these people ever use rife,
it's included in their book. I obviously talk about it in my book stop fighting cancer because that's a big
piece of what we do. Nina Silver wrote a great book, the handbook of rife frequency healing, which lays out
a lot of the different frequencies for people as well. This is the machine that we use. I have used four different
rife machines over the last 16 years. Currently, we use this one, it's called the true rife, that's the brand,
it's the F-117. This picture here isn't of the current model, but this is what we've used, no, maybe
the last seven or eight years and any patients that come to us that have cancer or chronic Lyme go home
with a rife machine, that's part of our program. They're in our office, we're skating them,
our real four pillars to anybody's disorder is find out what the cause is, and this is with cancer as well.
Number two, how are we going to get rid of the cause? Number three, what are we going to use from a
nutraceutical standpoint that includes diet, that includes exact specific cancer killers, or what are we
going to do to kill that chronic Lyme nutraceutical from a nutritional standpoint. And then fourthly, what are we going to use
from a frequency standpoint, that's what the greatest time in our office is to discover through a
skating, exactly what frequencies we're going to use for a patient. And then most of our program is
done so that the patient uses the rife while they sleep. It's very easy to sleep with, we sleep with one
at home ourselves, and it is a benefactor on this next slide. I show some pictures of it that's
going to enter a picture there is the best picture ahead of what's called the hammer tube on your bottom
left for the person's foot on top of it. It's called a hammer tube because you could basically hit it with a
hammer and it's not going to break. It's very easy to use at night and you're basically getting all your
treatment while you're sleeping so you can get up and live during the day and that's really what our
purpose is. So we said people home with a completely programmed unit has a little computer, that's a
great picture, not a very great one of what the screen looks like, it's very easy to use even if you've
never used a computer before. The reason why I like this is it's just so easily programmable and that's
what right initially didn't have with his machine because the computer technology just wasn't there yet.
It's very easy to use in bottom line even though I'm not a quantum physicist. It works and that's all I can't
care what it is as long as it works. So it just seems like it works so well on biblical principles. I mean
Jesus said he is the light of the world and it's amazing how God uses light to heal people. So I just
think it's a great benefit and it's been a super, super tool. It's just a tool. It's not a magic one. It's a tool
but it's a great tool that we've used in our practice. So if you need any more information there's a
chapter on rife in my book that goes into a little bit better detail on this but I hope this gives you a
great overview. Call our office if you have any questions or check out our website. Thanks.